you did awesome I don't know I don't
know anyway in this course you learn
that your options for images go well
beyond a simple image tag in fact you
can use the browser's properties to not
only change the source of the image to
ease bandwidth requirements but you can
also change the content of the image
using the picture element and you learn
that images aren't always necessary
there are markup alternatives like icon
fonts and CSS Styles they give you low
bandwidth options for images but most
importantly you learnt that images are
an integral part of your development
workflow for modern sites images
constitute an enormous percentage of
page load and screen sizes and form
factors vary so widely responsive design
requires preparing your images for any
device now you can develop images for
all of these devices Eddie heck yeah
what what see ya right